The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: This class
has been taught continuously
since 19--
the earliest record
I have of it is
1956, when Kevin Lynch probably
taught it for the first time.
Now this is the 34th year in
which I'm teaching the class.
I overlapped with
Lynch for two years,
and this is the last time
I'm teaching this class.
So I'm going to go through a
lot of small things, details,
plus some general idea about.
In 1956, Kevin Lynch
called this class
The Visual Form of the City.
Between '56 and '76,
he changed the title
to Theory of City Form.
I have kept the title the same
as it was originally, well,
the 1976 title.
I think the "theory,"
it gives the impression
that we have
significant theories,
as in post-Darwinian science.
We don't.
Our basis, our theological
basis is somewhat vague.
We are somewhere between
a science and an art.
In the Media Lab, they now have
a group called City Science.
I want to know what
City Science is.
We certainly know
what City Art is.
If numerical consequence is
the basis of City Science,
we will deal with that in
the appropriate manner.
We will also deal with
very difficult things,
such as the human
experience of built form,
which is not a scientific
phenomenon at all.
In fact, for those
of you interested
to have a background
in philosophy,
there's a new book
called Cosmos and Mind,
by Thomas Nagel, who's
a professor at New York
University, who argues that
Darwinian science has lead us
in the wrong direction,
that Darwinian science,
we can't explain concepts
such as consciousness or mind,
that we need a new teleological
approach to science
which would embrace these now
difficult to achieve responses.
I'm not a philosopher
nor a historian.
This is not a class in
history, although we
will use a lot of
information from the past
as examples to give us a
better idea of the present,
not that you shouldn't
know history.
If you're going to
take this class,
I would recommend
a couple of books.
There is no superb
urban history.
If there were, Harvard
or MIT would teach it.
It is bizarre that these
two great universities
don't teach urban history.
It's difficult to explain.
Partly, it's explained
by the traditions
of history and architecture.
Architecture, you cannot study
in the arts without knowing
history.
It's difficult to
achieve a degree in music
without knowing who Mozart
was, but it's very difficult
to achieve a good
degree in architecture
without knowing
who Palladio was.
But you can achieve
a degree in science
without knowing
who Copernicus was.
It's difficult to
avoid Copernicus,
but you may be able to.
There's no teaching
here at MIT in--
there's no required teaching,
in achieving an engineering
or science degree, in
the history of science.
There's no architecture
program that I know anywhere
in the world that doesn't
have a requirement that you
study the history
of architecture,
some poorly taught, of course.
I assume many of you are
architects by background.
Has anybody done urban history?
Has anybody in this class
taken a formal subject
in urban history?
OK, if you have, answer
the following question.
What theory would you assume
for the genesis of cities?
Why do cities exist?
AUDIENCE: We studied
Chinese urban history.
JULIAN BEINART: Oh, no, no.
You haven't answered
my question.
You've told me what
you've studied.
All right, we'll return
to this question.
Because we'll talk about
the conflicting theories
about the genesis of cities.
When did cities first
occur, time-wise?
AUDIENCE: As in the poor city?
JULIAN BEINART: I asked
you, give me a time, a date.
AUDIENCE: About 5,000 ago, AD.
JULIAN BEINART:
Yeah, I would now
claim Jericho to be the oldest
city, probably about 10,000 BC.
But if you say it's
[? South Alleyouk ?]
or someplace else,
paleontology is very vague.
Most of our understanding of
cities comes from archaeology.
There's no theory which
explains the origin of language.
There are multiple theories.
Cities occur very late in
the humanoid evolution.
The first tool is dated
at 2.6 million years
ago in the Olduvai Gorge in
Kenya, found by Louis Leakey.
So if cities date
from 10,000 years BC,
we have an anomalous period of
time from four million years
before Christ to 10,000 BC.
During that period of time,
a great deal of paleontology
has been--
one of the transformations
of the humanoid
to the human erectus
deals with nutrition.
Until you have a tool which
can make food possible other
than vegetables, you'll
have the capacity
to take in
nutritional substances
into the body, which
theoretically include
the creation of a larger brain.
So the brain size
of Australopithecus,
which is about four million
years old, a post-ape animal,
has a brain of about
400 cubic centimeters.
You have brains of about 1,200
to 1,400 cubic centimeters,
depending how big you are
and how smart you are.
I don't think smartness has any
connection to size of brain.
But I'm throwing in just
one other thought here
around the idea of the genesis.
I'll go into this more
carefully with you on Thursday.
There's a British
paleontologist-psychologist
called Robin Dunbar who studied
the increase in human brain
size and argues that human
brains increased more
significantly in
communities of 150 people
than when people
stayed on their own
or didn't partake in
rituals of 150 people.
This theory is called
the gossip theory
and argues that people
and children need
to be indoctrinated into the
rules of this settlement,
and it takes about 150
people to make sure
that these rules are
properly disseminated.
How this was done, nobody knows.
If you believe Chomsky's
theory of language acquisition,
you'll believe that human
beings have an innate capacity
for language, and
at a certain point,
almost like the strike
of a piece of lightning,
it was activated
in the human brain.
There are many,
many other theories.
I'm not a linguist
nor a philosopher,
but I'm just trying to explain
to you in a very primitive way
how the advent of cities is
late, how the advent of cities
is difficult to explain.
I will deal on Thursday with
two contrasting theories,
the theory of surplus, and the
theory of cosmic knowledge.
Let me go through some
of the practical things
that you need to know.
You're going to be
overwhelmed with reading.
You have to develop a mature
understanding of what to read
and what not to read.
I'm giving you an exercise.
The required reading is about
1,500 pages for the semester.
That's about four
books, four books
for graduate student
learning about cities,
the form of cities,
is not very much.
By the way, one of the
reasons for the increase
for the size of the reading
list is the enormous expansion
of material in this field.
I have in front of me the 1956
references from Kevin Lynch.
He totals 50 books, 51 books.
My expanded reading
list is 500 books.
Let me give you an example.
in 1964-- that's eight years
after Kevin Lynch started
teaching this class--
the first book that dealt
with third world cities,
or developing country
cities appeared.
1964, MIT published Man's
Struggle for Shelter
in an Urbanizing World, a book
by Charlie Abrams, still one
of the best books published.
Can you imagine
that the literature
on what now constitutes
the majority of the world
was not available in
English until 1964?
When I first started
teaching this class,
students wanted to
do papers on cities
where they came from, Nairobi.
There's no urban
geography on Nairobi.
Now there's an urban
geography on almost every city
that exists in the world.
When we did a studio
in Chandigarh 19--
god only knows when--
in the 1980's, I
think, you couldn't
get a plan of Chandigarh.
It was prohibited by
the Indian government
for security reasons.
The only one that you could
buy was through Russian sources
via Houston for $2,000.
So we did this study
of Chandigarh, which we
had to make our own base map.
Today, that would be ridiculous.
So if this class
has a bit of a lag,
it was built at a time
when there were few books,
and material on
cities was scarce.
I'm not here to teach for
history or for posterity.
I'm here to teach you as human
beings in the best way I can.
But I will talk, I
will cover the material
as best I can in about
40 to 45 minutes,
then I will show
illustrated material
in almost all the classes
for about 15 to 20 minutes.
And then there will be
a period of 10 minutes
for general observation.
If we cannot, as in the case
of case studies like Paris
and London, finish with--
there may be no time for asking
questions or deliberating
on the subject.
We may start the next class with
me asking your questions about,
what questions you have
about what I presented,
such as, why is Paris
twice as dense as London?
Why?
Both developed significantly
from 1750 onwards.
Why did London develop
less densely than Paris?
You should know these things.
AUDIENCE: The wall?
JULIAN BEINART: You're
right in some ways.
The wall, the last wall of the
five Parisian walls was built
as late as the 1820's.
London, there's a rule you
can, if you don't know European
history, and you don't
know European cities--
and some of you who come
from the Orient may not--
the fortification of
cities is more extreme
as you go eastwards
from England.
The wall of London was a pretty
miserable wall, a little bit
of it left in the gates,
like Ludgate and so on,
but basically, it
wasn't very much.
Vienna's walls were never
penetrated except in 1683
by the Ottoman Empire.
You don't need to know
all of these details,
but you have to understand
the conceptual structure.
Why would you build a city?
One of my favorite quotations
is from Marx talking
about the origin of cities.
He says "the antagonism
between town and country
begins with the
transition from barbarism
to civilization, from tribe to
state, from locality to nation,
and runs through the whole
history of civilization
to the present day."
The first antagonism
he talks about
is between town and country.
Cities were always
clearly demarcated
between town and country.
It took until
renaissance for nature
to be introduced in the walls,
within the womb of the city.
The Romans used to say, I
think, [LATIN],, they are lions.
The world outside the walls
was a world of treachery
and difficulty and fantasy.
There are many
ideas about cities
which are complex as that
idea, but the antagonism
between country and
city still lasts today.
President Obama was elected
because of the majority
that he had in cities.
The Democratic Party
is an urban party,
by and large, although this
has changed significantly
as the size of
cities has changed,
and as the demarcation of
polling districts has changed.
But we'll talk about this
distinction between country
and city, and in
the third class,
we'll deal with
the organic model.
But you could see
somebody like Marx,
who really tried
to do everything,
and was right about 50% and
wrong about 50%, judgment
about the significance
of the advent of cities.
We know relatively little
about these things,
and I tend to prefer histories
which deal with examples.
So Morris's book The
History of Urban Form,
or Braudel's book on
the Mediterranean,
or on the structure of
everyday life are better than--
although Lewis Mumford,
The Culture of Cities,
is still the standard.
He's wrong on many things,
but he's full of ideas.
It's a Mumfordism to claim--
anyway, forget about Mumford.
We'll talk about
him sufficiently.
Let's see in these
generalized notes.
By the way, there
are other reasons
why Paris is more
dense than London.
There's not one simple reason.
What kind of houses
did Englishmen live in?
As opposed to what
kind of houses did,
during the time of Haussmann,
did the French live in?
We'll go into some of those.
Look, I'm not a historian, and
this is not a class in history.
It's a class in deriving
ideas from a number of sources
and arguing them with you.
I have no, other
than a lot of time
spent teaching and
preparing for this class,
and a lot of external
experience practicing in cities
all over the world, I have no
golden formula for the truth.
I don't claim to have that.
I'm not sure that I believe
anybody who says they do.
I'm not a theist, and I'll
come across quite often
as an agnostic, if not
an atheist, with regard
to truths of religion.
Jerusalem has only been the
capital of a city, of a country
twice, once during the
period of the 10th century,
during the crusader
occupation, and after 1948
with the advent of Israel.
Jerusalem, which we will do in
great detail in one case study,
is subject to an enormous
number of philosophical
interpretations of history.
There is no single
truth about Jerusalem
that is outside the truth of
geopolitics at the moment.
This is true for much of--
so if I, to use
the term "theory,"
which Kevin Lynch started--
I will use the term--
I would have not called this
class Theory of City Form.
We live in a predominantly
scientific age, in which theory
is theory in physics, and it's
about as precise as it can be.
Theory in the social
sciences is much looser,
in theory in city form
is even looser than that.
So I would have
called it, this class,
really, more preoccupied
with normative ideas,
normative and functional ideas
about the former cities, rather
than theory.
If I taught this
class in Paris, I
would be deriving
theory from theory.
This class follows
the Chicago style,
and I only will
discuss a theory if I
can attribute an example
in association with it.
So I will be making propositions
and choosing an example
to adumbrate that proposition.
The example will come from
architecture very much.
Amongst the social
sciences or disciplines
other than urbanism, if there is
such a thing as the discipline
of urbanism, much of my material
will come from the built world.
It's a bias, which I accept,
and it's the only one
that I know a little bit about.
So for instance, if I want to
talk about the problem of how
you deal with the future
expansion of a city,
I will look at the plans of
university buildings designed
in competition from
1955 and 1960 to 1990,
where an attempt to design for
a system which could accept
change is much easier to see.
I'll also refer to
a thesis done here
on MIT, which looks at
the way MIT has been
able to expand using the
same trajectory of expansion,
formal expansion.
What else?
As for the definition
of a city, I'm
going to use any definition
that you wish to bring forward.
Cities are, by and large,
denser than non-cities.
And that's about
all you can say.
The SMSA definition
of a metropolitan area
is useful for
statistical purposes,
but god alone knows
what Mexico City,
what are the boundaries
of Mexico City?
There's more investment
outside of the city
of Mexico City in
the metropolitan area
than there is in
the city itself.
Is Foxborough, where the
Patriots play football
every Sunday during the winter,
part of the metropolitan area
of Boston?
The city of Boston had nothing
to do with the decision
to locate it in Foxborough.
As cities have
expanded horizontally,
so the issue of what the
boundary of a city is
becomes more complex
and more interesting.
There are more new prototypes
of urbanism created
by the expansion, or horizontal
expansions, and more anger
by architects who believe
that cities should still be
framed as if they were walled.
Both of these arguments
are pretty viable,
and will be worth
discussing them.
OK, I'm going on and on and on.
Any questions about procedure?
You're all very silent.
Has anything I've
said been wrong?
That's amazing.
You're much too gullible.
Look, I will, at
times, say things
which I feel more strongly
than I feel about other things.
That's my privilege,
because I teach this class.
If you taught the class, you
would have that privilege.
You are absolutely free to
question everything I say.
Let me just say something,
which I hope you'll remember.
In one of the evaluations
of this class, which
is done every year, there was
a question from the students
as to why they didn't
ask more questions.
And one of the number of
answers here, the professor
knows too much.
My response is, would you prefer
to be taught by a professor who
knows too little?
That's a stupid response.
Please just don't feel because I
have had 34 years of experience
teaching this class, that
you should understand it
all without question.
I feel free to diverge
and choose opportunities
to say things which come
to me for the first time.
That's the way I think.
I would like you to
think in the same way,
even if you might get
irritated by my presumption.
There is no single theory
of city form that exists.
There is no absolute theory.
There are many theories, and
there are preferred theories,
as opposed to silly theories.
There are many, many problems.
Robin Dunbar's theory of 150
people has been taken up,
and firms, corporate firms,
have divided their manpower
into groups of 150 people
based on Dunbar's studies.
We're not going to do
something as silly as that.
Reading, there's two pieces
by Kevin Lynch generated
in this class
through discussion.
And I think they ask questions
which are interesting,
and answers which
are interesting.
The first three classes,
starting on Thursday, deal--
well, let me generalize first.
There are three major
sections in this class.
Section one deals with the
nature of city form theory
and goes on till the fourth,
goes on till the sixth class.
The first six classes deal
with examples and ideas
about the form of cities.
There are three
analogical examples.
The first one, which I'll
deal with on Thursday,
posits a metaphysical
relationship
between the form of
the city and the cosmos
that will deal with
all of the material
from paleontologists
and philosophers,
like Mircea Eliade,
who will argue
that the archaic
cities had connections
to celestial systems.
We want to ask why.
What are the
implications of survival,
in terms of practical
methods of dealing
with survival in the
form of the city,
as opposed to metaphysical?
Why is the temple of Marduk,
the city god of Babylon,
on top of the Tower of Babel?
Estimates of the Tower of
Babel are about 300 feet
in brick and stone.
You can't build much
taller than that,
although the pyramids of Giza
are about 300 meters, I think.
Why place a temple
on top of a tower?
We will ask questions
of this kind.
We will ask why, this
is one of the earlier--
and you can help us here--
one of the earliest
cities of dynastic China
has a pattern which resembles
the star system of the dipper.
Essentially, Lynch,
Mumford, Adams,
are amongst the
major protagonists
of the cosmic theory
of archaic city form.
By this theory, it means we know
where a city should be located.
We have techniques
for finding the place
where it should
be best built. It
has a relationship
with survival.
It has three-tiered systems.
One of the things
I will do, is I
will give you a piece, a series
of pieces of paper every class.
So for instance,
instead of me having
to make a list of
all of the reasons
for why the cosmic, or what
the cosmic form can do,
I will hand it out to
you on a sheet of paper.
This is a gift.
You would have 26 gifts
at the end of the semester
to add to your numerous
amounts of paper.
I will often show
a diagram which
I can't show in slide form to
help us manipulate the class.
I will sometimes try
to bring the class up
to date by giving you a
piece from the New York
Times that day.
The New York Times will
come up in some of these.
One of the problems with
teaching a class for 34 years
is that you get bored.
Most of you who graduate from
MIT with advanced degrees
teach.
I don't know how you teach
the calculus for 34 years
without going around the bend.
So what I try to do is to
teach the class differently
every time I teach it.
So I will start off taking
a piece from this morning's
paper on Hurricane Sandy and
what Mayor Bloomberg proposes
to do, and tie it
into the theory
that we're examining that day.
And I will give you that piece
of paper, or those sheets
of paper, sometimes three.
Sometimes I'll give
you a series of plans
which will take five pages.
For instance, when we talk about
the Grand Paris competition,
I will give you excerpts
from the competition.
So I'll give you a paper.
You can throw it away.
You can use it during the class.
It's an adjunct.
You can give me gifts in return.
Don't take that seriously.
The second of the analogical
propositions we look at
will be the machine model.
These three models were derived
in this class with Kevin Lynch
a number of years ago, and
I've adapted them for this
and modernized them.
The machine model
deals with everything
from the first grid city
to the laws of the Indies
to contemporary attempts
at machine interpretation.
The fourth class looks
with the tradition
of regarding the city
as a function of nature
and looks to organic analogies.
We will look at a
number of theorists
of this kind, Patrick Geddes,
Ebenezer Howard, and so on.
But I will be
skeptical about this.
I'm skeptical about biomorphism,
and I will say I'm skeptical.
I will go through
very briefly with you
the history from 1933
of the greatest planning
effort in this country, the
Tennessee Valley Authority.
I will show you how in
1933, I will tell you
about Roosevelt's theoretical
understanding of nature.
I will talk to you about the
Southern urbanists' reaction
to that, viewing nature in
a completely different way.
I will talk to you about
Henry Ford's proposition
to build Muscle Shoals as an
industrial-agricultural city
instead of the new.
Henry Ford proposed to
the United States Congress
to buy the first
dam for $1 million,
and the Senator Norris,
great man, turned it down.
Instead, we'll go on to
new images of nature,
and we'll talk about
the establishment
of the controversy about the
small fish in one of the dams.
We'll go on to the fact
that the 28 dams are now,
the 28 dams that are
built no longer provide
sufficient hydroelectric
energy, and 60%
of the industry supported by
electricity comes from coal.
The worst coal disaster, the
worst environmental disaster
in history took place in the
Tennessee Valley Authority.
You see what I'm trying to do?
I'm trying to say nature
is not a fixed commodity.
In one project, there are annual
protests against the-- where
did the Manhattan Project--
where was the Manhattan Project?
It was in the Tennessee
Valley Authority.
There are anti-nuclear
protests every year.
Nature is a difficult subject.
Forget about nature.
You're a human being.
You have an animal.
You have a brain many,
many times the size
of any other living creature.
Your decisions are not bad ones.
At least that's
my point of view.
I'm a humanist.
Forgive me.
I'm not a naturalist.
We'll debate that proposition.
I then will spend
two classes looking
at theoretical
propositions, one largely
from the social sciences,
economics, political science,
history, and so on.
And then I will look at four
attempts to create reasonable
theory, Lynch,
Martin, Alexander,
[? Brockin ?] and
[? Helia ?] as examples.
We will stop there
with the introduction.
That is a large
introduction to the class.
I will start Section 2
with the first early cities
of capitalism.
Nothing that preceded
in human history,
as far as urbanization
is concerned,
is as important as what
happened from 1750 onwards.
I will try to convince you
not to ignore urban history--
it's not taught anyway--
but to really concentrate on
the period from 1750 onwards.
The greatest event
in human history
is the Industrial Revolution.
Why it took place in
England, why it took place
in the first place, we will look
at a number of theories which
explain that, including a
recent theoretical exploration
by a man from
California called Clark.
His book A Farewell to Alms
is an interesting biogenetic
attempt to explain the
change in human behavior
in the 19th century in England.
In 1850, London was the
largest city in the world.
It was the first city
in the world since Rome
to have achieve 1 million
population, more or less.
We don't measure these
things very accurately.
At the same time,
the first rules
were introduced into boxing.
Why?
Medieval boxing was dealt
with cruelty to animals.
I would treat you to the
story about the burning
of a cat in front of
royalty in the population
in Paris in the 18th century.
Boxing in a medieval
sporting event was--
didn't separate big
giants from small men.
Women didn't box.
Cockfighting, Hemingway
says that bullfighting
is the last vestige of sport.
What he's saying is
that the transformation
from free-ranging animal-human
interaction in medieval sport
changed dramatically
with industrialization.
1855, the Marquis of
Queensbury rules in boxing
limited the length of boxing
around to two minutes, I think,
or five minutes, whatever it is.
That's when Manchester
United was formed.
So we look at sport as an
analogy to culture in relation
to--
we'll deal with Marx.
Not Marx, Marx, yes.
We'll always deal with Marx.
You can't avoid him.
We'll deal with Engels' period
in Manchester and his book
The Condition of the
Working Class in England.
We'll deal with a
number of things
when we do the case
study of London.
We'll deal with a number
of economic and social
transformation, which I
consider fundamental to any
consideration of a modern city.
The first is the invention
of the mortgage system.
None of you know anything
about the mortgage system.
Nobody knows very much.
Do you realize that
one of the great causes
for the American depression
was that you couldn't
engage in a domestic
mortgage to borrow money
for buying a house?
That was invented as part of
the feudal system in Manchester
and Birmingham in
the 1830's onwards.
I'll talk about the
conquest of cholera
in London, in the
building and the--
London in 1850 with
a million people
with the most filthy
city in world history.
There were a number of
people who made livings
just scavenging the dirt in
London, in the Thames, digging
out bodies, old waste.
Cholera was considered to be
a disease through the air.
A wonderful doctor,
there's this great book
which I refer to in reading.
The Ghost Map is
the book which goes
into detail about how this man
discovered that cholera was
a waterborne disease, which led
to the greatest public building
works in the history of London,
the redistribution of water
from the North and the South
into bypasses which takes
the polluted water horizontally
away from the center of London.
We'll do the same with Paris.
Here I will deal with another
fundamental innovation,
and that's deficit spending.
You cannot do major works in a
city without borrowing money.
The great conflict amongst
the prefects of the Seine
until Haussmann about building
as much as the purse would
allow, which was very little.
Haussmann benefited
from the great work
of Saint-Simon and
other economists
which showed that if
you borrowed money,
you could pay it back
at enormous benefit.
Haussmann borrowed enough
money in the years between 1850
and 1870 to rebuild Paris.
That loan, those loans
were only repaid in 1928.
Deficit spending has become--
if you're interested, we can
talk about deficit spending,
national deficit spending.
The great trauma, economically,
in United States politics
is an extension of
deficit spending.
Most of the Democrats
believe that a large deficit
isn't a fundamental flaw
in the economic system.
Republicans, by and large,
have the opposite position.
They believe that
a national economy
is much like
developing a mortgage.
You can't have too
large a mortgage,
as opposed to how much
economic growth you have.
We will touch on this
economic distinction,
and I'll refer you to reading a
book by the Nobel Prize winner
Joseph Stiglitz, who talks
about the fundamental problem
of disparity, large disparities
of income as measured
by the Gini coefficient,
and economic growth.
But this starts in
Paris in the years,
in the 20-year period
from 1850 to 1870.
Now, architects look
at Haussmann and say,
he built avenues.
If you don't like avenues,
you say he's a horrible man.
If you like avenues, then
you think he was a saint.
He did lots of other
things than build avenues.
He built the avenues according
to an economic relationship
with the banks, which
allowed him to borrow
enormous amounts of money.
So we'll move on from the case
studies of Paris and London,
which are classic--
I should hurry up--
to looking at one of the
conventional 19th century
responses to the first
cities of capitalism,
and that's Barcelona.
We'll look at the genius
of Ildefons Cerda's
plan for Barcelona, the
largest housing plan in Europe,
a number of issues.
I presume some of you have
been to Barcelona and know
the Ensanche.
Almost every theorist
from Barcelona,
including my friend
Morales, who died last year,
claims there's something
significant in the Ensanche.
I want to know what you think.
Has anybody-- who's
been to Barcelona?
You all better go
before the class.
There are number of intriguing
things about the competition
which set one against a modern
proposition for modular growth,
as opposed to the neoclassical
proposition of the man
who he defeated.
We'll look at it Ildefons
Cerda in a way which
very few people
tend to look at him,
and that's part of
a neo-Marxian notion
of what urbanism should be.
We'll look at a man from
Paris who came to this country
with the new Icarian system.
Anyway, we'll look
at Vienna, again,
as the reuse of infrastructure.
Vienna is interesting
for a number of ways,
not only the building
of the Ringstrasse,
but for the 1683 attempt by the
Ottoman Empire to take Vienna.
Vienna was within one
morning of being taken over
by the Ottomans.
The Ottomans succeeded in
defeating Christianity in 1453
by using a German
cannon which had
to be schlepped across Europe
to Istanbul by 30 oxen.
They had to build bridges
on the way over there
to cross a waterway.
When they brought
it to Istanbul,
it destroyed the Christian
double wall and moat
by sending rocks
1,300 meters away.
The attempt to defeat Vienna
after crossing all the way
from Istanbul is very
well-documented in a very good
book.
But the savior of
Vienna for Christianity
by the intervention of the
King of Poland's cavalry
is one of these extraordinary
events in history
which, had it not
happened, Vienna
would have been an Islamic
city, and Europe's future
would have been without Sigmund
Freud, Beethoven, Mozart, et
cetera, et cetera.
Now, that may be
better for Europe.
I'm not arguing that I know.
But it's one of the cardinal--
it's in connection
with the wall,
because the Islamic
engineers dug under the Earth
and built a tunnel under the
southern wall into the center.
So walls didn't pay
off, altogether.
After these case studies--
well, the last of the case
studies will be Chicago.
Chicago has no aristocracy,
only a middle class
and immigrant population,
and is one of the few great
19th century cities.
Which other cities were
developed in the 19th century?
Can you name me one?
AUDIENCE: San Francisco.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
it's a bit dubious
about what its origins are.
But you are maybe right.
Johannesburg is certainly one.
Chicago is unusual in
really only having been
developed from 1830 onwards.
Chicago is also unbelievably
interesting in relation
to the role of
the private sector
in the development of a city.
The European examples
really deal with governance.
The private sector
in Chicago built
an illegal underground
subway system
without the city knowing it.
Now, if you have a city
which has enough hubris
to allow a private subway
system to be built,
it also deals with the
Chicago World's Fair
and the various
episodes leading to it.
We'll spend some time going
through the Chicago World's
Fair, and we'll contrast it with
The Devil in the White City,
the book which many
of you probably know,
and the incredible lack
of public governance
in a city which
was being developed
by the private sector.
Section 2 will end with two
classes, one on utopianism,
which I dislike as an idea.
But we'll do the class anyway.
You may enjoy it more than I do.
But the interesting--
we'll realize
the link between
English and the Shakers.
Do you realize
that the woman who
started the Shaker movement
came from Manchester,
and after having, I think,
her fifth stillborn baby,
she reviled against six,
left to the United States,
and came to start
the Shaker utopian
movement in this country.
There's a relationship
between the evils
of capitalism, pre-hygiene
and the utopian movement.
Utopianism has many
interesting followers.
And then we'll do a brief
look at some 20th century
organizations in England,
the British Town Planning
Movement after 1946, and the
socialist city in Russia.
Look, all of these
are enormous topics,
and I'm just going to
select a couple of ideas
and go with those ideas.
This is an enormous
attic of stuff.
This class is over-fat
and tries to do too much.
It's the accumulation of 34
years of not being on a diet.
So you have thoughts of
the fragments of stuff.
The last half of the class
deals with current theory
and practice.
The first section deals
with the question,
is there a
relationship, or what is
the relationship between the
way a city is made and its form?
The second group deal with,
what is the relationship
between social structure
and spatial structure?
And here we do case studies
of Jerusalem, Johannesburg,
the border between Mexico and
the United States, and colonial
Delhi in India.
That takes us to the
third week of April,
and it's spring already, I hope.
And we can keep these windows
open for the sun to come in.
I deal with a number
of propositions,
formal propositions,
number 20, four models--
sorry, number 19, four models.
One deals with modern
and postmodern urbanism,
deals with the
origin of modernism,
and mainly the CIM
discourse on urbanism
and some reactions to it.
Number 20 deals
with the proposition
about the city as an
opportunity for building
in an open-ended fashion,
questions of prophecy,
questions of
imagining the future,
questions of finding
formal structures which
can accommodate change with the
minimum cost are part of this.
I will look at the
previous research done
at the Cambridge University
Build Form and Land Use Studies
Group, Leslie Martin
for six weeks.
I will look at the opposite
notion in the work,
in the theories of Leon
Krier and Aldo Rossi, two
European theorists,
which those of you
will know from
architecture, postulating
that it is the past that
should govern any preoccupation
with the form of a city.
Rossi has a theory
of monumentality
which we need to examine.
Krier has some intelligent
but really remarkably stupid
notions about classicism, and
the revival of classicism,
and that cities were great
during classical times.
And this is the derivation
from neoclassicism which
we need to look at carefully.
We need to take a careful
look at the way in which we
derive notions from history.
The next class
deals with memory.
Memory and history are two
different things in urbanism.
I will try to explain it through
the attempt, to which all of us
have, for maintaining
continuity.
We'll deal with the work, the
writing of Maurice Halbwachs,
the book Collective Memory, and
other examples of the conflict
between history and memory.
Pierre Nora is writing
about the French,
about the loss of living
memory through history,
that history displaces
living memory, and so on.
But the fact that we
now have more stuff
in cities than ever before,
and are building less and less
and reusing more
and more material
argues for look at memory.
The last few classes
deal with the difference,
the contemporary difference
between the public and private
domain, the relationship
between the external,
the [NON-ENGLISH] and
the [NON-ENGLISH],,
the suburbs and the center
city in the United States.
The last few classes
will take a brief look
at splintering urbanism,
the effective modern virtual
communication
systems on the form,
of the predicted form of
cities, take a brief look
at the effective issues
of climate change
and sustainability.
On the last day of
class, I will deal
with a major issue of the
Gini coefficient and poverty.
In my view, one
issue which urbanism
is doing less about
than any other,
and is theoretically seemingly
incapable of doing that,
that is reducing
the level of poverty
in the non-European,
non-American world.
That's an animal, a
nasty animal which
we bypass, as we do any serious
attempt at universal climate
change theory.
It's what I think the
nasty future holds for us,
and we'll end with that
rather dismal proposition.
On the other hand,
I'll at the same time
be talking about the
wonderful successes
that we've achieved
over 10,000 years,
well, a little more
than 10,000 years,
but 10,000 of
human history, just
to be able to teach this
class with all of this stuff.
Whether it's a good
class or a bad class
is only due to the
fact that we've
accumulated enough experience.
We've had enough human minds
thinking about urbanism
for this period of time.
It's a major, major achievement.
Marx is right.
Without cities, there'd
be no civilization.
And without civilization, we
wouldn't be sitting here today.
But the two gaps, one
of which, of course,
Marx and Engels
made a living off
was picking up on the
notion of the inability
to deal with the unnatural
distinction between wealth
and poverty, and what that
means in the latest attempts
by groups such as Slum
Dwellers International.
I don't know if any of you saw
the exhibition at the United
Nations last year or
the year before produced
by the Cooper Hewitt museum
on third world cities.
OK, so you don't know.
What else?
Is that enough for one semester?
We're going to go
quickly, and I am not
going to be able to explain
second order, third order
issues.
This is an open-ended system.
It's got infinite dimensions.
We're going to look at
the core dimensions.
And if they lead
us outward, great.
Maybe you'll have a
universal theory of urbanism
by the end of this class.
I haven't got one.
Any questions?
You're all very silent.
If you find a piece of reading
in this class schedule,
you will find the reference in
the thicker bibliography I've
given you, if it's up to date.
And I hope it is.
I check it every year and
try to keep it up to date.
If you have any trouble
with a book or a reference,
just send me an email.
I like the email system,
because it allows
me to do things in my own time.
But if you need to
talk, let's talk.
That's an open invitation.
We are all very busy people.
So for instance,
when I mentioned
Halbwachs and his book, The
Collective Memory, it's not--
I will quote a bit
from it in the class.
But I purposely didn't put
it as required reading,
because you'd have to
read the whole book.
There's a part of me
which had an upbringing
that I had to read whole books.
You couldn't read a
piece of Shakespeare.
We were beaten over our heads.
We've got five minutes.
We were beaten over
our heads if we
came in and read only a piece
of Henry V, famous speech.
I am understanding of the
amount of energy and time
it takes to read.
So I've tried to
give the required
readings as parts of books.
There's not one whole book
that I've referred to.
In the case of Halbwachs,
it's very difficult
to extract a chapter.
There's a wonderful
chapter on memory
in music, which fascinates me.
I mean, whenever I hear somebody
conducting Mahler's Ninth
Symphony without a
score, I'm amazed
at how it is humanly possible
to understand such complex music
and direct it for two hours, an
hour and 40 minutes, perhaps.
He tries to explain that
individual memory is
impossible, that
the social memory is
what creates individual memory.
He was a collectivist
sociologist
and wrote some brilliant
things about memory.
But there's a case,
if you read the book,
it'll be worth reading.
Maybe I'll excite
you about the book.
OK, I'll see you next
Thursday, if you continue.
If you don't, good luck
with the rest of your life.